so far during this pandemic whenever the
government has introduced new
restrictions
the labour party has supported them but
will that continue well labour's
shadow business secretary lucy powell
joins us now from manchester thank you
uh for being with us uh lucy powell so
the prime minister is expected to
announce tomorrow that families will be
able to meet up over christmas
is that a good idea is that a good idea
well let's see what those uh plans are
but i think what we now need
for the first time really in this uh
pandemic
is we need a lot more clarity we need a
blueprint
a route map to take us through from now
through to to next year so that families
know uh
what they're supposed to be doing when
more importantly or just as importantly
so that businesses
can plan whether they are reopening and
if they are
under what terms and and how they can
continue over the coming weeks and there
are still
many many businesses who despite the
briefings in the papers today
won't know whether they can now stock up
on food whether they can start taking
bookings again
whether they can plan to reopen their
businesses so
we need methodical measured
uh clarity not what we've seen before
which is
over briefing then pulling back the
drawbridge at the last minute
mixed messages stay at home go to work
stay at home go to work
we need this now to be a route map
through to next year when hopefully
the vaccine and mass testing will will
come on stream and make things easier
for all of us
so you say on a route map but that's
what we're going to get tomorrow isn't
it we're going to
find out what the plan is for christmas
we're going to find out what the tier
system is going to be that's going to
replace
the national lockdown in england and
then on thursday we'll find out
after the data comes in who's going into
what tier and the question was about
christmas uh public health england has
said
that for every day that restrictions are
relaxed over christmas we'll have to pay
for it with five days of increased
restrictions so what's labour's position
should restrictions be relaxed over
christmas
well look i think we all want to be able
to see our families in some way
over christmas but we don't want to do
that in a way that we then have to pay
a heavy price in in the following weeks
i think what we want is
is measured uh clarity uh so that we can
yes see our families in some small way i
think we all recognize that christmas is
going to be a very very different kind
of christmas
uh this year but it's not just about
christmas it is about
the coming weeks and the weeks after
christmas as well and that's why we need
this clear
route map instead of you know what we
get from the government is just sort of
focusing on
one small aspect which then gets over
briefed and overplayed
and then they have to pull back the
drawbridge at the last minute and you
say
we'll find out all these things this
week i don't know whether we will
and what criteria the government is
going to be
uh using for that because if you're a
hairdresser's in harlow this morning or
a
restaurant in manchester or or a bar in
newcastle
or a brewery in middlesbrough you don't
know whether you can start to restock
whether you can start to brew the beer
whether you can start to take the
bookings
and if you're in the events industry or
the weddings industry or aviation
you will your businesses be able to
begin
to start working and operating again and
these are businesses that are now
absolutely on their knees after many
many many months of
real difficulty of mixed messages of
changing
uh guidelines of changing uh measures
and and really now you know this whole
point of this national lockdown
was to have a reset moment if you like
uh and i worry that we've lost
two weeks of that now with with the
psycho dramas going on in number 10
and the infighting in government they
could have used this time much better
to make it really clear to people what
are going to be the criteria to go into
what's here
what measures will be in those tiers and
how we can all have a route map
from here through to next year okay i'm
still not
totally clear i'll be honest what
labour's position is on
christmas but we should move on to the
spending review of course
which we're expecting will be dominated
by the pretty dire state of the public
finances some really difficult decisions
for the chancellor to make we're
expecting him to potentially announce a
freeze on public sector pay
given the state of the finances given
the fact that uk debt is now bigger than
gdp
these kind of measures something that
the chancellor needs to consider
well i don't think he does need to
consider that
at this point in time because actually
at this point in time when we're in the
middle of a crisis we're not even
vaguely in the recovery phase yet when
you're in the middle of a crisis
you can't cut your way out of that
crisis and you can't really
do that when you're at the beginnings of
the recovery either because you'll choke
off the recovery
in people stopping going out and
spending
their money and helping getting the
economy going so yeah we've got what
we've got to remember about the context
of this comprehensive spending review
is that we are in a much worse position
than many of our other
counterparts in terms of countries and
economies
we've seen the biggest drop in gdp of
all of our european competitors
and we're in a much worse position
because the government's uh constant
sort of
playing catch up and coming to the to
the table too late with support packages
and measures and frankly a lot of what
they're bringing forward doesn't meet
the scale
of the challenge that we face so we're
in a worse position
and economically it would be the wrong
thing to do to cut
back the public finances just at this
point in time
but of course it would be morally
absolutely a kick in the teeth wouldn't
it
for all those front-line workers who've
helped support us
through this pandemic from the bin uh
collectors to those working
in public health in the much in the
mortuaries the fire fighters and so on
this would be an absolute kick in the
teeth for them
after what has been a horrendous few
months and will still be a difficult few
months to come
well let's um we'll put some of that to
the chancellor rishi sunak
when he's on the program later on this
morning we're getting
to crunch point finally should we say on
brexit now of course i know that there's
still some key decisions to be
ironed out particularly on fishing and
level playing field but at the same time
we know
we know really the direction at least of
where this trade deal is going and it's
going to come down to
being a choice between quite a basic
free trade deal
or no deal so what is labour's
position are you inclined to support the
trade deal
when it comes back to the house of
commons
well we've always said that we want
there to be a deal
that is our starting point we have now
left the eu so the arguments about leave
and remain
are over we're now coming to the end
we're very near the end
of the transition arrangement and the
very
best uh situation that we could get for
this country in that context
is a trade deal is a deal with the with
the eu
yeah we would like that to be as
comprehensive a deal as possible so that
businesses and jobs can be protected in
this deeply
uncertain time the last thing businesses
need right now is all the uncertainty so
just to be clear then you're inclined to
support a trade deal
we'll we'll see the detail when it comes
but you know our starting point is that
we want a deal
okay so that would definitely be our
starting point okay now pretty patel
has apologized after an official report
found she breached the
ministerial code and her behaviour
amounted to bullying
should she resign
i think her position is completely
untenable absolutely she's been found
uh by an independent inquiry of breaking
the ministerial code
uh and i think if you are found of
breaking the ministerial code
your position is is completely untenable
and i think it's appalling that the
prime minister
has decided to uh back her instead of
sacking her
and that's what he should have done and
just to follow up her on that
last year luciana berger left the labour
party because of what she described as a
culture of bullying bigotry
and intimidation tom watson said that
she was bullied out of her own party
by racist thugs so is labour only tough
on bullying when it's the conservatives
not at all i think look bullying uh
doesn't know
party political lines and i think we can
all be found
uh wanting when that comes and and
certainly the the behavior that luciana
was subject to
was appalling it was gross it was
grotesque
and that's why kierstarm has been very
clear that rooting out anti-semitism and
taking a tough line
on those who are anti-semitic or indeed
those who are
acting in a bullying way won't have a
place
in the labour party and he's very clear
that he would have he would have sacked
pretty patel or any other labour mp
who'd been
uh found wanting in that in that way so
it's it's not that
bullying can't exist in in all political
parties of course it can and it
does believe me it does it's how you
deal with it it's how you tackle it
and it's whether you show the leadership
and the tough decisions that you need to
take
to root it out talking about leadership
and tough decisions jeremy corbyn's been
suspended from
labour after his reaction to a report on
anti-semitism in the party
and just a very brief answer because we
are running out of time but
should jeremy corbyn be your labour mp
well look kier has taken uh the the
very clear decision to remove uh the
whip from
jeremy that's his uh right as leader
because
uh he was not happy uh with the response
that jeremy gave
in reaction to the very damning ehrc
report recently so i think as a very
first step
jeremy corbyn should apologize for for
that
uh reaction and hopefully then we can
all move on from this saga
okay lucy powell thank you very much for
being on the program thank you
very much for being here thank you